The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN OPPENHEIM: In the
last several lectures,
we've considered a
number of procedures
for designing digital
filters for the class
of infinite impulse
response filters.
And the two primary
design techniques
that we considered, in
fact, the two useful design
techniques that we developed,
were the techniques
which we refer to as
impulse invariance, and also
the bilinear transformation.
You recall, hopefully, that
both of these techniques
are techniques that correspond
to mapping a continuous time
or analog filter to
a digital filter.
What I'd like to
do in this lecture
is consider an
example of the design
of a digital low-pass filter
using each of these techniques,
using impulse invariance and
the bilinear transformation.
And hopefully this will give
you a better feeling for how
both of these techniques work.
The class of analog filters
that I would like to use
are the class of so-called
analog Butterworth filters,
which are a useful
class of lowpass analog
and digital filters, and also
a relatively simple class.
To first of all, define
the class of analog filters
that we're considering,
they are the class
of analog Butterworth filters.
And this class of filters is
defined by the analog system
function H sub a of j omega
magnitude squared of the form
1 over 1 plus j omega divided
by j omega sub c to the 2N.
Now, there are two parameters
in this expression.
One is what's referred to often
as the cutoff frequency, omega
sub c.
And the second is the
order of the filter,
namely N. Let me
remind you that we're
looking at here an expression
for the squared magnitude
function.
And so we have a 2N here.
But in fact, N is
what corresponds
to the order of the filter.
Well, if we look at
this frequency response
characteristic, we observe
that at omega equal to 0,
the gain or the magnitude
squared is equal to unity.
At omega equal to omega sub c,
the j's of course cancel out.
this term then is equal to 1,
and we have for the magnitude
squared function, a half.
Or for the magnitude
function, which
is what we're looking
at here, 1 divided
by the square root of 2.
So at omega equal
to omega sub c,
an analog Butterworth filter has
a magnitude which is down by 1
over the square root of 2.
And the other important
characteristic
is that the frequency response
is a monotonic function
of capital Omega.
So that as capital Omega
increases from 0 to infinity,
the magnitude or the
frequency response
is a monotonic function.
Well, we observed that the
cutoff frequency, the parameter
omega sub c, adjusts in a
sense where we might divide
the frequency characteristic
into passband, transition band,
and stopband.
We have another parameter,
which is the parameter
N, the order of the filter.
And basically the effect
that the parameter N has
is to affect the shape of this
frequency response in the sense
that if capital N is larger,
the frequency response tends
to be flatter longer, so that
for a larger N than what I've
drawn with the black curve,
the frequency response might
look more like this and
then drop off sharper.
Whereas if capital N
is smaller, then it
will be less flat
in the passband
and drop off more slowly.
So in fact, the way
that I've drawn it here,
this is the behavior of the
frequency response curve
as the parameter
capital N increases.
So, the higher the
order of the filter,
the sharper the
drop from what we
could consider as a passband
region into a stopband region.
And obviously then, the
sharper the filter we want,
the higher order
filter we would design.
Now, to look at
the pole 0 pattern
or the 0 pattern really
of the Butterworth filter,
we can convert this expression
into an expression relating
the magnitude squared
function expressed
in terms of the Laplace
transform variable s.
And so this expression
corresponds to the product
H sub a of s times H sub a
of minus s, evaluated at s
equals j omega, in
which case the j omega
is what corresponds to s, and
so H sub a of s times H sub
a of minus s is of
the form 1 over 1 plus
s divided by j omega sub
c raised to the 2N power.
Well, what we recognize is
that this expression has poles,
if we solve this equation.
This expression has poles
at of course the roots
of the denominator polynomial
or at s sub p equal to minus 1
to the over 2N
times j omega sub c.
That's simply solving the
equation with this denominator
polynomial equal to 0.
Well, we can see
more specifically
where these poles
lie in the s plane
by recognizing that these
are the 2N roots of minus 1.
And then we have a
j, which corresponds
to e to the j pi over 2.
So we can rewrite this
expression for the poles
as s sub p equal to e
to the j pi over 2N.
That's one of the roots of
minus 1, plus k times 2 pi
where k is an integer.
This generates the
roots of minus 1.
We need to multiply by
j, and we can do that
by multiplying by e to
the j pi over 2, which
is equal to j times omega sub
c, which is the cutoff frequency
parameter for the
Butterworth filter.
So this then specifies
where the pole locations
are for the Butterworth filter.
For example, if we
consider the case,
let's say with n equal to
3, k let's say equal to 0.
That says then that
we have a pole at e
to the j pi divided by 6,
e to the j pi over 6, times
e to the j pi over 2.
In other words, we have
a pole in the s plane
at an angle of pi
over 6 plus pi over 2,
which corresponds
to this location.
Then we'll have poles
distributed in angle
around a circle in the
s plane, distributed
in an angle where the
angular spacing is pi over 3.
The pi over 3 arising from
a consideration of 2 pi k
divided by 2N, where in
this case, N is equal to 6.
So these poles are distributed
equally spaced in angle
on a circle in the s plane.
For N equal to 3, the
angular spacing is pi over 3.
For k equal to 0 that first
pole corresponds to this one,
and then we continue around.
Now these are poles
distributed on a circle, which
tends to look like the z plane.
But I stress that what
we're talking about here
is the s plane.
In particular, we're talking
about the analog frequency
response design as the class
of analog Butterworth filters,
which we're then going to
map to digital filters.
So this is a circle
in the s plane.
It's often referred to as
the Butterworth circle.
And it has a radius which
is equal to omega sub c.
In designing an analog
Butterworth filter then,
the procedure is to
appropriately choose
the parameters omega
sub c and capital
N. Those are the parameters of
the analog Butterworth filter.
And then from the poles
distributed on the Butterworth
circle, this gives us the pole
locations for the product,
H sub a of s times
H sub a of minus s.
We can then simply associate
with the transfer function
H sub a of s.
The poles in the
left half plane,
to generate a stable filter,
and then the ones which
are contributed by the
factor H sub a of minus s
are the corresponding image
poles in the right half plane.
The procedure then is to design
a squared magnitude function.
Talking about a
Butterworth filter,
we choose these
parameters omega sub c
and N. That tells us where
the poles are located
on the Butterworth circle.
From the pole locations for
the squared magnitude function,
then we can factor that into
H sub a of s times H sub
a of minus s, by
choosing the poles that
fall in the left half
plane, to give us
a causal, stable analog filter.
All right.
Well, that is an analog filter.
What we would like
to talk about is
the design of a digital filter.
And the procedure that
we're going to go through
is to choose a set of specs
for the digital filter,
and then decide on what the
corresponding specifications
should be for the analog filter,
depending on whether we're
using impulse invariance or
the bilinear transformation,
design the analog
filter, and then map
the result to a
digital filter using
one of those two techniques.
So let's choose a set of
digital filter specifications
for a digital lowpass
filter with a passband which
occurs for frequencies
now in the digital domain,
for frequencies below 0.2 pi,
and a stopband region that
occurs for frequencies
greater than 0.3 pi,
and the transition band then,
of course, is the region
in between those.
So, we would like to design
a digital filter, which
stays within some limits
in this passband region,
drops below some limit, delta
sub s in the stopband region.
And we'll choose as the
limits in the passband,
unity for the upper limit and 1
minus delta sub p for the lower
limit.
Where delta 1 minus
delta sub p might not
and in fact it won't turn out to
be 1 over the square root of 2,
in other words, this
cutoff frequency
will not necessarily correspond
to the parameter omega sub
c for the Butterworth filter.
All right.
Well, so let's choose a
set of specifications.
The ones that I've chosen
are the requirement
that the frequency response
characteristic be within 1db
of unity in the passband.
In other words, the requirement
that 1 minus deltas sub
p be greater than or
equal to minus 1db.
So this deviation
must be less than 1db.
And then the requirement
that in the stopband
the frequency response
characteristic
is below minus 15db.
In other words, the
stopband attenuation
for frequencies greater than 0.3
pi is greater than minus 15db.
It's further down
than minus 15db.
So delta sub s is less than
or equal to minus 15db.
The one other specification
that we'll impose,
or in fact, it's really
a consequence that
will result from using
a Butterworth filter,
is the fact that the frequency
characteristic is monotonic.
So we have the passband
edge, the stopband edge,
the passband ripple
or deviation,
and the stopband
ripple or deviation.
And we can, of course,
rewrite these specifications
in terms of requirements on the
transfer function or frequency
response, the magnitude
of the frequency response.
The requirement that the
deviation be less than 1db
in the passband is
the requirement then
that 20 log to the base 10 of
the magnitude of the frequency
response--
that's the deviation db--
be greater than or equal to
minus 1, or that the magnitude
be greater than or equal
to 10 to the minus 0.05.
And of course, we wanted
also to be less than unity,
and that's an implied condition.
So it must be less
than unity, and it
must be greater than or
equal to 10 to the minus 0.05
for frequencies
from 0 to 0.2 pi.
So in particular,
since it's monotonic,
we'll impose that condition
at the frequency point 0.2 pi,
corresponding to the
end of the stopband
and the beginning of
the transition band.
The second condition
that we impose
is the condition
that by the time
we get to omega
equal to 0.3 pi, we
would like the frequency
response to be down at least 15
db, and more if possible.
But the condition
is that the 20 log
to the base 10 of the magnitude
at omega equal to 0.3 pi
must be less than or
equal to minus 15.
So this says we must be
further down than 15 db,
or we can translate that into
a condition on the magnitude,
so that the magnitude of
that frequency is less than
or equal to 10 to
the minus 0.75.
Well, let's consider two--
we want to consider
two design procedures.
Let's first consider the impulse
invariant design procedure,
in which case we would like to
convert these specifications
on the digital filter to
corresponding specifications
on the analog filter.
Now, we know that
from discussions
that we've had previously that
if we have an analog frequency
response and we apply impulse
invariance to the impulse
response, the digital
frequency response consists
of the analog frequency
response scaled in frequency so
that capital Omega is equal
to little omega divided
by capital T. And then
that scaled replica of H
sub a added to itself delayed
by little omega equal to 2 pi, 4
pi, et cetera.
That is multiples of 2 pi.
So, that means then that
the digital filter is scaled
repeated replicas of
the analog filter,
and so we would choose
the analog filter
to have similar specifications
to the digital filter,
but with the corresponding
frequency parameters dictated
by this transformation, capital
Omega equal to little omega,
divided by capital T. Well, that
of course neglects aliasing,
and in fact as we go through
the impulse invariant design,
we'll initially
neglect aliasing.
And a rationale for doing this
or a reason why, in fact, it's
not unreasonable to
do that, will emerge
as we go through the example.
So for the time
being, in fact, we're
going to neglect
aliasing, so that we'll
think of the analog and
digital frequency responses
as simply related by this
substitution of frequency
variable, capital Omega
equal to little omega
divided by capital T.
Well, that leads us then to
the analog frequency response
which I've depicted here.
We had a factor of 1 over
capital T in the amplitude
of this expression.
So for the digital
filter to result
with an amplitude
of unity at dc,
we would scale the analog
frequency response by capital
T. So the important values
then in capital Omega
are the ones corresponding to
little omega equal to 0.2 pi,
or since capital Omega is
equal to little omega divided
by capital T. We have a passband
edge occurring at capital
Omega equal to 0.2
pi over capital T,
and a stopband edge equal
to 0.3 pi over capital T.
At this passband edge,
according to the specifications
on the digital
filter that we want,
we would like the frequency
response for frequencies
below this--
In other words,
in the passband--
to be between capital T
and capital T times 10
to the minus 0.05.
That's the guarantee that
we have less than 1 db
ripple in the passband.
And for frequencies
greater than 0.3 pi,
we would like to be
below capital T times 10
to the minus 0.75.
That's the guarantee that
we're down 15 db or more
in the stopband.
The way I've drawn it here,
I've implied that I will exactly
meet the specifications
at the passband edge,
and exactly meet
the specifications
at the stopband edge.
You can imagine, of course,
that if I did that and then
converted to a digital filter
using impulse invariance
that there would be an
effect due to aliasing, which
in fact would result
in my not meeting
exactly the specifications
at the stopband edge.
And that's a point that we'll
deal with in a few minutes.
All right, well now we
have our specifications.
Let me incidentally
point out that there's
this parameter capital T
that we're carrying around.
And as I'll justify partly
on the basis of this example,
the parameter capital T is
an irrelevant parameter.
It's a parameter
that will disappear.
We'll carry it through with
us for this one example.
But for other
examples and problems
that you work through
the study guide,
you should have
absorbed the fact
that capital T is irrelevant,
and in fact capital
T can be chosen equal to unity.
But let's carry it
through in this example,
and just see how it disappears.
All right.
Well, so we want the
analog Butterworth filter
meaning these specifications.
And we want it at
omega equal to 0
to have a gain magnitude squared
function to be T squared,
so that the magnitude
is T. So here we
have the form then of the
analog Butterworth filter.
And in order to meet
these specifications
at this frequency and this one,
we then have two equations.
One equation says
that at capital Omega
equal to 0.2 pi
over capital T, we
would like the value of
the magnitude function
to be T times 10
to the minus 0.05,
which implies that
this denominator should
be equal to 10 to the 0.1.
Second of all, at the
stopband frequency,
0.3 pi divided by
capital T, the fact
that we want the magnitude to
be T times 10 to the minus 0.75
implies the magnitude squared
is of course the square of that.
And we want then the denominator
to be equal to 10 to the 1.5.
So we have two points that
we're trying to nail down.
We have two parameters,
omega sub c and N.
From these two points that
we're trying to nail down,
we get two equations.
And we can now solve these
equations for our parameters,
omega sub c and capital N.
Well, if we do that, and it's
a little tedious to do it,
let me point out
incidentally since we're
trying to keep track
of this capital T,
that capital T drops
down into the numerator
and so, in fact, we can solve
for capital N and omega sub
c times capital
T. In other words,
we can just move this
down here algebraically.
And so we have then instead
of the parameter omega sub c,
we have the parameter omega
sub c times capital T.
If you grind through
these two equations,
what results is a value for N
equal to 5.8858 and probably
some other digits.
And omega sub c capital
T equal to 0.70474.
And we could imagine
that at this point
we're done, except
that the parameter N
corresponding to the order
of the filter, of course,
has to be an integer.
So, what that means is that
we can't use the value of N
as I've indicated here.
We need an integer value.
Also if we were to round
this down or truncate
it down to a choice
of N equal to 5,
then since the
order is lower you
can imagine that the
filter characteristics
won't be as good.
In other words, we're not going
to meet these specifications.
So the other choice then is to
use instead of this value of N,
use a value of N equal to 6.
In other words, round up
to the next integer value.
And if we do that then
these two equations
will no longer be satisfied.
We're now using a
higher order filter
than these equations
would dictate.
Of course, we're using
an integer order,
because that's what we need.
We're using a
sixth order filter.
And what that means is that
if we choose N equal to 6,
we can satisfy this equation,
or we can satisfy this equation,
but we can't satisfy
both of them.
Well, which one
should we try to meet
and which one should we exceed?
Well, we know that
with impulse invariance
there is the issue of aliasing.
And so in fact, in
impulse invariant design
it will often happen that
although we design exactly
to meet the stopband
specifications,
the stopband
specifications won't
be met because of aliasing.
Consequently, given the
flexibility that we have,
due to the fact that we can
actually implement a higher
order filter than
these equations
dictate, to compensate
for aliasing
we can exceed the
stopband specifications
and meet exactly the
passband specifications.
So if we substitute
for N, N equals 6
into this equation
that then requires
that omega sub c T be
such that we exactly
meet the passband
specifications, in which case
this equation won't be met.
In fact, what will
happen at the stopband
edge is that the
stopband specifications
will be exceeded.
If we do this, then we
have for the equation
that we solve for
omega sub c T from,
the equation which specified the
passband edge, which is where
we're going to meet the specs.
And what results then is for
omega sub c T, this value,
rather than the previous
value that had been obtained
from the two equations.
Well, from these
parameters then,
we have that omega sub c is
0.7032 divided by capital T.
We can substitute these
parameters into the form
for the squared magnitude
function, H sub a of s times H
sub a of minus s,
and actually it's
this raised to the 2N,
which is the 2 times
sixth power, which
is the 12th power.
So this then is the form for
the analog squared magnitude
function.
Now notice that the
parameter capital T still
hasn't disappeared.
We still have it.
We have it there,
and we have it here.
But notice that when we
substitute in for omega sub c,
this number divided
by capital T if you
track through that
algebra, capital T
reappears in this expression
as a multiplier on s.
That is we had 0.7032
divided by capital T.
That gets reflected back
up into this numerator,
so that we have s
times capital T. Well,
let's see what that means.
Suppose that capital
T were equal to 1.
And we got an analog impulse
response, H sub a of T,
or the system
function H sub a of s.
If instead we
reinserted capital T
and considered H
sub a of s times
capital T multiplied
by capital T
that impulse response would
be related to this one
by simply a time scaling.
In other words,
this one would be
replaced by H sub a of t
divided by capital T. Well,
let's look at this and ask
what happens when we sample it
at samples spaced by capital T.
So, we look at this
impulse response
with T replaced
by n times capital
T, as we've specified here.
And we observe that no
matter what we pick capital
T to be that
parameter disappears.
Because little t
equal to n times
capital T gives
us samples H sub a
of n, which are exactly the
same samples that we would
get no matter how we chose
the parameter capital T,
or equivalently whether or
not we chose the parameter
capital T equal to unity.
I think that it requires
a little reflection
to absorb this point.
It's basically tied to the fact
that the frequency response
is specified for
the digital filter,
not for the analog filter.
And specifying the
frequency response
for the digital
filter, in effect,
specifies capital Omega
times capital T. Well,
I leave it to you to
think about this a little.
But the important point is
that, in fact this parameter
T, if we specify
the filter in terms
of digital specifications,
this parameter capital T
is really irrelevant.
All right.
Well, so here is
our analog design.
And we can obtain H
sub a of s from this,
according to the
method that we talked
about previously taking
the left half plane
poles of this expression.
Converting those
to a digital filter
by using the transformation
that we discussed
in the previous two
lectures, expanding,
for example, in terms
of residues and poles,
and then applying the impulse
invariant transformation.
And if we do that, what results
is a digital lowpass filter,
which was the lowpass filter
that we set out to design.
And let me just show how
those specifications,
or how that design comes out.
So this, for the example that
we've been talking about,
is a graph of the frequency
response characteristics.
Here is the magnitude as a
function of digital frequency
omega.
And here is the same
frequency response
plotted in terms of db.
And we see that we had
in the specifications
a passband edge at 0.2 pi,
a stopband edge at 0.3 pi.
At 0.2 pi we asked that
the gain be down by 1db.
And of course, it's hard to tell
exactly that we're down 1db,
but in fact we are.
At omega equal to 0.3
pi, our specification
was that we wanted
to be down by 15 db.
In fact, we overcompensated,
because of the fact
that we had to round the order
of the filter up to an integer
value.
And you can see, in fact, that
if you look at this carefully,
we exceed the specifications
of 0.3 pi by a little bit.
In other words, we're down
by a little more than 15 db.
In fact, for this
particular filter
you can imagine that the
effective aliasing is, in fact,
rather minimal.
Because this frequency response,
by the time we get out to pi
is essentially 0.
Here we're down to minus 75 db.
And that's, of
course, the amount
that would get aliased back in.
So this is the resulting filter
frequency characteristics
for the impulse
invariant design where
we exceed slightly the
stopband edge specifications.
Now, the next thing
that I'd like to go onto
is the corresponding
design, the design
or the corresponding
Butterworth filter,
now using the bilinear
transformation
rather than using
impulse invariance.
I remind you that the basic
idea with the bilinear
transformation, as we've
discussed in the last lectures,
is that we basically choose
the analog specifications
by pre-warping the
critical frequencies
for the digital filter through
the nonlinear distortion
curve corresponding to the
bilinear transformation.
So, we would start here
for the digital filter.
Of course, here we're talking
about a monotonic filter rather
than one that ripples.
But we have a passband
edge at 0.2 pi,
a stopband edge at 0.3 pi.
We reflect those
critical frequencies
through the arctangent
curve to obtain
the corresponding
critical frequencies
for the analog
Butterworth filter.
When the analog Butterworth
filter is designed,
we then obtain the
digital Butterworth filter
by transforming this filter
back through the bilinear
transformation.
So, let's look at how
this design works then.
We have, as we've just
reflected on that curve,
we begin with the digital
frequency specifications,
reflect those through the
bilinear warping curve
to the analog specifications,
and consequently
the critical frequencies--
and let me emphasize
first of all that
just as with impulse
invariance, you
can show that the
parameter capital
T is an irrelevant parameter.
We could, in fact, carry
it all the way through.
And what would happen is that
we would find that no matter
what we chose capital T to
be, the digital filter design
that resulted would
be exactly the same.
So in fact, for this example
I'll work through it simply
with capital T equal to 1.
All right.
With capital T equal
to 1, we reflect
these critical frequencies
into this passband frequency
edge and this stopband edge.
And consequently,
the analog filter--
this is the analog filter--
the analog filter that
we design is one that
meets these specifications.
And consequently we have,
again, the two equations
that say that at
the passband edge,
we want the magnitude to
be within 1db of unity.
And at the stopband edge,
we want the magnitude
to be less than, down
by more than 15 db.
And the two
equations that result
are these, exactly the same as
we had in the impulse invariant
case, except that the
frequencies are different.
So now substituting in for the
form of the analog Butterworth
filter into these expressions,
and setting this up
for equality in
these expressions,
what results then are
the two equations which
are identical to
the two equations
that we had for the
impulse invariant design,
except that the frequencies at
which the passband and stopband
edges of the analog Butterworth
filter fall are different.
They're different because of the
warping of the bilinear curve,
or the pre-warping
that we have to apply.
So, these are the two equations.
And if we solve these two
equations for capital N,
the resulting value for capital
N is 5.3 and some digits.
Notice incidentally
that it's less
than it was for the
impulse invariant design.
And in general that's
a characteristic
of the bilinear transformation.
But so it's less, but
it is not an integer.
So the first thing
we can ask again
is, could we just simply
truncate this down or round it
down to the nearest integer
value, in other words,
N equals 5.
But of course if
we did that, then
we wouldn't be able
to pick omega sub c,
so that these equations
were satisfied or so
that the specifications
were met or exceeded.
So in fact, we need to choose,
we have to choose N equal to 6.
We have to choose the next
highest integer value.
Choosing N equal to 6,
we then have the choice
of exactly satisfying
this equation,
or exactly satisfying
this equation, or in fact
not satisfying
either one of them,
but playing back and
forth between the two.
Well let's do it in
a particular way.
We can, for example,
exactly meet
the stopband specifications.
In other words, we can use
N equals 6 in this equation,
and solve for omega
sub c, in which case
the passband specifications
will be exceeded.
Recall that in the
impulse invariant design
we did it the other way around.
We met exactly the passband
specifications, in which case
the stopband specs
were exceeded.
But there we had a good
reason for doing that.
The reason that we did that
is because we knew in advance
that in any case the passband
specs wouldn't be met exactly,
because of the
effect of aliasing.
For the bilinear
transformation, we
don't have a problem
with aliasing.
So, in fact, we're free to play
with this flexibility in a more
general way.
All right.
Well, in any case then if
we meet the stopband specs,
substituting N equals
6 in this equation,
and solving for omega
sub c; we end up
with a value for omega
sub c, which is 0.76622.
And so this then gives us
the parameters omega sub c
and N for the analog
Butterworth filter.
We can then use
those specifications,
again to generate
the pole pattern
for the squared magnitude
function H sub a
of s times H sub a of minus s.
Factor this by choosing the left
half plane poles in s plane,
and then mapping this function
to a digital filter using
the bilinear transformation.
And let's now look at how this
filter comes out as compared
with the digital Butterworth
filter that we obtained
by using impulse invariance.
Well again, I have a display of
the magnitude of the frequency
response and also
the gain in db.
From what you may
recall from the curve
that I showed previously,
this looks roughly the same.
It's a monotonic
filter and drops off.
It's down by some
amount at 0.2 pi,
and the stopband is at 0.3 pi.
In particular, according
to the specifications,
we wanted this to be down by
no more than 1db at 0.2 pi.
Well, it's hard again to say
that this is 1db or less.
But if we look at
0.3 pi, we can see
that this is in fact
exactly down by 15 db.
And that's the way
that we designed it.
We designed it to exactly
meet the stopband cutoff
and exceed the passband cutoff.
And then the frequency response
continues on from there.
It's interesting, in fact,
to compare the design
that we got from the bilinear
transformation with the design
that we got previously
with impulse invariance.
And let me do that by
superimposing the two of them.
So that the one that
I'm putting on now
is the impulse invariant
design, and let
me just lay them on
top of each other.
OK.
You can see incidentally
that looking at the frequency
response on a magnitude
plot there, in fact,
are some differences.
This line has gotten
a little thicker.
That is, the two don't
exactly superimpose.
But you can't really
see the differences.
Whereas you can when we look
at this on a logarithmic plot.
In particular, this is
the frequency response
that corresponded to the
bilinear transformation.
This is the frequency
response that corresponded
to impulse invariance.
And this is, in general,
a characteristic
of the use of the
bilinear transformation.
It's a result essentially
of the frequency distortion,
because we've
taken the frequency
axis and the continuous
time frequency axis.
As you run along it
at a constant rate,
it gets compressed more and
more along the digital frequency
axis.
That wasn't well said.
But what I really mean to
say is as we walk along here
at a constant rate, the farther
we walk, the faster we're
running along the j omega axis.
And that's why, in fact, the use
of the bilinear transformation
on a lowpass filter will
give better attenuation
at the higher frequencies
than impulse invariance will.
And I don't know
if you can really
see the fact that the
passband specs were exceeded
for the bilinear design.
In fact, when you look at these
view graphs in the study guide,
I think you'll see that
for impulse invariance
the curve is slightly lower
than it is for the bilinear
transformation
OK well, look.
This is a simple example that
hopefully at least illustrates
for you the basic
procedure involved
in carrying through a design
of an infinite impulse response
filter using impulse
invariance and the bilinear
transformation.
There are other examples that
are considered in the text.
There is a discussion of
digital Chebyshev filters,
in other words digital
designs beginning
from an analog Chebyshev filter.
And you'll also
have an opportunity
to carry through some
designs in the study guide.
A point that I would
like to mention briefly
is that most of the
discussion, in fact
all of the discussion
that we've gone through,
has focused entirely
on lowpass filters.
In fact, the
discussion generalizes
in a fairly straightforward
way to bandpass, bandstop,
highpass, et cetera filters.
In particular, as is discussed
in some detail in the text,
there are a class of
frequency transformations
that allow lowpass
designs to get
converted to bandstop, bandpass,
highpass, et cetera designs.
So this concludes our
discussion of design procedures
for recursive or
infinite impulse response
digital filters.
In the next lecture I'll discuss
the design of finite impulse
response filters,
and in particular
introduce a number of
designs, one of which
corresponds to a class
of algorithmic designs.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]